THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
REACHING INTO THE TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE, WIDENING ITS CRIMINAL
PROBE INTO THE CAPITOL RIOT.
MARK SHORT, MIKE PENCE REVEAL TO
CNN HE TESTIFIED UNDER SUBPOENA
BEFORE A FEDERAL GRAND JURY
INVESTIGATING THE INSURRECTION.
SHORT IS THE HIGHEST RANKING
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL
KNOWN TO HAVE TESTIFIED BEFORE
THE GRAND JURY.
AND PENCE'S FORMER CHIEF COUNSEL
ALSO TESTIFIED BEFORE THE GRAND
JURY.
>> SO TODAY, TRUMP'S BATTLE
BEFORE THE GOP PLAYS OUT IN AN
INTERESTING SPLIT SCREEN.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS BACK IN
D.C. FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE
LOSING THE ELECTION AND LEAVING
TOWN IN DISGRACE, FOLLOWING THE
CAPITOL RIOT.
HE IS ABOUT TO GIVE A KEY NOTE
SPEECH TO A CONSERVATIVE GROUP
FOCUSED ON, OF ALL THINGS, LAW
AND ORDER.
THIS MORNING, FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE GAVE A SPEECH
URGING CONSERVATIVES TO FOCUS ON
THE FUTURE AND AVOID LOOKING
BACK.
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE DOJ
INVESTIGATION.
OUR SENIOR CNN ANALYST AND
FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
WHY IS MARK SHORT SO IMPORTANT
TO THE DOJ?
>> THIS IS A BIG DEAL BECAUSE
FOR THE FIRST TIME WE KNOW THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS GOTTEN
INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE.
MARK SHORT IS THE HIGHEST
RANKING PERSON WHO WE KNOW HAVE
OF WHO HAS BEEN SUBPOENAED TO
THE GRAND JURY.
SHORT WAS THE CHIEF OF STAFF TO
MIKE PENCE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HE SAID IN
THE GRAND JURY.
HE WON'T TALK ABOUT IT.
BUT WE DO KNOW HE TALKED TO THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE AND HE HAD
THIS CRUCIAL MEETING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE IN THE OVAL OFFICE
WHERE DONALD TRUMP AND THIS
LAWYER, JOHN EASTMAN, WERE
TRYING TO PRESSURE MIKE PENCE TO
THROW OUT ELECTORAL VOTES FOR
JOE BIDEN TWO DAYS LATER ON
JANUARY 6th.
WE KNOW THAT SHORE AND PENCE
REJECTED THAT IDEA.
MARC SHORT WAS SO ALARMED THAT
HE ACTUALLY NOTIFIED PENCE'S
SECRET SERVICE DETAIL.
HE SAID TO THE COMMITTEE, MY
CONCERN WAS FOR THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S SECURITY, SO I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
HEAD OF THE VICE PRESIDENT'S
SECRET SERVICE WAS AWARE THAT
LIKELY AS THESE DISAGREEMENTS
BECAME MORE PUBLIC, THAT THE
PRESIDENT WOULD LASH OUT IN SOME
WAY AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
ENDED UP HAPPENING.
>> I MENTION THAT HAD GREG
JACOBS ALSO TESTIFIED BEFORE THE
GRAND JURY.
EXPLAIN HIS SIGNIFICANCE.
>> HE'S ANOTHER IMPORTANT
PLAYER.
HE WAS COUNSEL TO MIKE PENCE AND
HE REALLY PUSHED BACK AGAINST
JOHN EASTMAN ON THIS LEGAL
THEORY THAT THE VICE PRESIDENT
IN HIS XAS AS THE CINCINNATI HAS
THE LEGAL AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY TO REJECT CERTAIN
ELECTORAL VOTES.
AT ONE POINT HE TESTIFIED THAT
HE MADE THIS, WHAT I THINK IS A
REALLY INTERESTING ARGUMENT
ABOUT WHY THAT CANNOT BE.
JACOB THAT THAT PART OF MY
DISCUSSION WITH MR. EASTMAN WAS,
IF YOU'RE RIGHT, DON'T YOU THINK
THAT AL GORE WOULD HAVE HAD JUST
DECLARED HIMSELF PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES?
AND JOHN EASTMAN ACKNOWLEDGED
THAT HIS PLAN WOULD LIKELY
VIOLATE THE FEDERAL LAW.
THE ELECTORAL COUNT AND WOULD
LIKELY LOSE 9-0 IN THE SUPREME
COURT.
THE REASON THAT'S IMPORTANT, IF
THEY KNEW THE PLAN WAS ILLEGAL,
THAT COULD BE TO CRIMINAL
INTENT.
>> THAT'S SUCH A GOOD AL GORE
ARGUMENT.
I HADN'T HEARD THAT.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THE SLATE OF
FAKE ELECTORS.
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THAT IN BJORK.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING WE KNOW THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS LOOKING
THE AT.
THE WAY THIS IS SUPPOSED TO
WORK, IS THAT AFTER EACH STATE
VOTES, THEY FILL OUT THIS
CEREMONIAL PAPERWORK WHERE THEY
SAY WE THE STATE OF GEORGIA, FOR
EXAMPLE, HERE BY AWARD OUR
ELECTORAL VOTES TO JOE BIDEN.
YOU CAN SEE IT ON THE LEFT WHERE
THESE 16 ELECTORS SIGNED THEIR
NAME.
BUT RUDY GIULIANI ENGINEERED
THIS SEVEN-STATE PLAN TO SUBMIT
FALSE SLATE OF ELECTORS WHO
CLAIMED THEY HAD BEEN PROPERLY
ELECTED FOR DONALD TRUMP.
THIS COVERED SEVEN STATES.
WE KNOW THAT RUDY GIULIANI WAS
THE COORDINATOR.
THIS DIDN'T JUST HAPPEN
ORGANICALLY INDEPENDENTLY, IT
ALL FLOWED THROUGH RUDY
GIULIANI.
WE KNOW THE COMMITTEE HAS LOOKED
AT THAT AND WE HAVE REPORTING
THAT THE DOJ IS INTERESTED AS
WELL.
>> WE'VE SEEN THIS STATEMENT
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS SUPPOSED
TO HAVE GIVEN THE DAY AFTER THE
ELECTION WITH JUST SOME LINES
SCRATCHED OUT AND SOME MOTORS
IS.
THIS IS SUCH A REVEALING LOOK.
THIS IS A DRAFT OF THE STATEMENT
HE WAS PLANNING TO GIVE THE DAY
AFTER, ON JANUARY 7th.
IF WE LOOK AT WHAT DONALD TRUMP
TOOK A PEN AND CROSSED OUT, IT
INCLUDES THIS STATEMENT.
QUOTE, I AM DIRECTING THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO ENSURE
THAT ALL LAW BREAKERS ARE
PROSECUTED TO THE FULLEST EXTENT
OF THE LAW.
END QUOTE.
DONALD TRUMP SAID, NO, I'M NOT
SAYING THAT.
IMAGINE THAT.
THE DAY AFTER WE'VE SEEN PEOPLE
DAMAGE THE CAPITOL, HE WOULD NOT
MAKE THAT KIND OF A STATEMENT.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY TELLING US
HIS STATE OF MIND, HIS INTENT
AND WHAT HE FELT ABOUT THE RIOT
THE DAY AFTER.
>> HE DOESN'T WANT THEM
PROSECUTED TO THE FULLEST EXTENT
OF THE LAW.